[Musique]
vous avez vu il se rend compte qu'il
s'est trompé de date je pense qu'on est
le 12 en réalité on est le 13 il n'y a
pas plus superstitieux car Windsor et
surtout avec le chiffre 13 il faut quand
même savoir qu'en 70 ans de règne
Élisabeth de n'a jamais présidé une
table où ils étaient assis à 13 la
cabine le Britannia ne n’a jamais
comporté de cabines numéro 13 et on peut
peut-être se dire aussi que je dis et
merde en plus on est le 13 et voilà
cette tâche qui a composé
superslam il a dans l'autre moi je vois
plutôt ici quelqu'un qui nous montre
qu'il est humain
il passe une semaine tous les jours 8
heures par jour devant les caméras entre
un enterrer sa mère en costume il change
trois fois par jour de costard il
enchaîne tout sans problème on a gardé
un truc sur 10 jours
est-ce que on a vu la reine d'Angleterre
feu et diabète on n'a jamais vu des
bêtes faire petite comme ça de porter
des gants donc déjà ça aurait été un
petit peu moi
elle faisait son job c'est une femme
différente il faut accepter pour le job
donc il est pas prêt pour le job voilà
attendez on a 50 ans on a une autre on a
encore des images
sont accablées sont accablés regardez
c'est pas grave
il faut qu'il redescend le roi bah je
l'ai regardé regardez regardez
je vous l'accorde et au revoir en effet
que c'est
lui peut-être l'ombre d'une chose quand
même en tout petit peu et simplement je
voudrais dire que il n'a pas été élevé
comme monsieur et madame tout le monde
depuis il est tout petit on lui dit un
jour tu seras roi Charles un jour tu
seras roi il appartient à la galaxie
Windsor et de ce ne sont pas des êtres
comme vous êtes
élégant quand même
le jour de l'enterrement de sa mère
quand même il a viré tout le personnel
d'un de ses palais
un nouveau chef d'entreprise il arrivait
avec ses équipes et vous redéployer les
équipes qui sont sur place mais juste le
jour de l'enterrement de sa mère non
vous préférez qu'on fasse on fait
semblant pendant trois semaines et puis
qu'on les a pas de respect oui
avec ces deux-là ils ont toujours raison
alors juste quand même là c'est une
énorme crise économique
c'est quand même la bagarre c'est la
situation est terrible pour le peuple le
peuple britannique comment il va faire
le le roi avec tout ça parce que entre
la dîme ça coûte paraît-il une livre 50
par anglais 66 par contribuable très
exactement
en train de vie qu'il ne va plus être le
même maintenant la crosse le danger de
Charles III c'est de ne pas trop
estomper la magie parce que si ça
fonctionne les Windsor c'est parce que
les chevaux ils sont blancs les carottes
ils sont en or il vivent à Buckingham
Palace c'est pour cela que ça que ça
fonctionne un petit carrosse en plaqué
or ça passe
le problème c'est la première ministre
la première ministre elle a déjà
interdit d'une sortie
bien sûr juste le problème c'est que
visiblement dans la série Netflix pour
revenir à Angers visiblement Mégane et
le petit prince avait annoncé que son
père était justement un peu comme ça un
peu capricieux un peu mais un peu
grossir même si ça le problème oui mais
justement ils sont dans la merde du coup
ils sont à remontage de la série qui
soit plus favorable à la famille donc et
il y a aussi apparemment une vraie
compétition ils sortent les photos
officielles en même temps le couple
Harry et Megane en même temps que ceux
de la famille royale et en fait ils
suivent le même planning mais chacun
dans leur coin et il y a une espèce de
compétition comme ça qui serait le vrai
problème avec Henri Mégane c'est que ils
veulent exister en tant qu'arrivée
Mégane mais ils sont dus et du chef de
sucer que c'est ce qu'il est faite
vraiment c'est donc c'est très compliqué
pour eux parce que un jour ils sont du
chèque du cancer les arrange quelque
part c'est ce que certains gens pensent
ils sont du quai du chef quand ça les
dérange ah non non on n'est pas comme ça
vous comprenez on est libre on fait ce
qu'on veut en même temps on signe
attendez qu'ils aient plus d'oseille ils
vont revenir au château de ferme mais
c'est probablement ce qui s'est dit
c'est probablement ceux qui se dit les
on pense quand même qu'il y a eu une
discussion franche entre le roi et son
fils ou à un moment donné il a dit voilà
je suis prêt à sortir le chéquier même
si j'ai du mal avec les stylos alors
justement alors que tout cela s'arrête
pour tenter de les muscler mais ceux qui
sembleraient c'est que ce soit trop tard
parce que le contrat d'édition voilà et
voilà
il va faire un chèque mais non ils vont
faire un chèque comme pour en gros la
reine elle avait elle avait payé pour
qu'on étouve l'affaire là il va faire un
chèque pour qu'on est tous le livre
croyez-moi je déconné les rois c'est mes
copains euh on a on a mis prévu pour
début de 9 ans voilà on a un autre
extrait où on voit voilà là pour le coup
le roi
il est plutôt sympathique il y aura
aussi un livre et fait une allusion à ce
qu'il a fait donc peut-être ça
l'humanise un petit peu voilà un petit
peu c'est trop bon
[Musique]
voilà donc il a il a un petit peu
d'humour il est très rare rock n' roll
j'aurais pas juste là mais c'est
beaucoup de dame qui collectionnent les
les lunettes de toilettes non mais
justement et ça ne me manque pas